Дуже дякую колегам з голосу за право
виступити це та тема яка об'єднує
сесійну залу і яка для нас колег з
голосом є особливо болючою масове
вбивство українських військовослужбовців
волинівці своєю жорстокістю вразило світ
це не тільки порушення міжнародного
гуманітарного права женевських конвенцій
і законів війни це яскраве свідчення що
Росія - це країна терорист де немає
жодних моральних Галь на Це вбивство
відреагували країни світу так само є
спільна заява тих структур українських
які займаються сьогодні звільненням
військовополонених - це гурт служба
безпека України але російські покидьки
вони не заспокоюються на 24 серпня у
Маріуполі російські терористи готують
показове судилище над українськими
військовослужбовцями щоб показати спробу
їх відрізати і зламати І от в цьому
контексті колеги де голос парламенту
наша фракція зареєструвала постановою 76
27 це звернення до всіх парламентів
світу з вимогою не просто засудити
масове вбивство українських героїв у
оленівці що безумовно є фактом тероризму
А ще і ще раз нагадати міжнародним
гуманітарним структурам в тому числі
міжнародному комітету Червоного Хреста
про їх відповідальність за те щоб мати
доступ до міцної свободи і допомогти
нашим військовослужбовцям пережити цей
терор а родинам дати надію і вибачте
будь ласка Ми не можемо на
погоджувальній раді поставити Цю заяву в
порядок денний тому ми з фракції голос
звертаємося зараз до президента з
проханням поставити в порядок денний
постанови 7627 і вибачте будь ласка
серед цих військовополонених які там є
не тільки військові там є цивільні слова
4 лікарів парамедиків госпітальєрів
серед них Катерина Поліщук пташка 21 рік
це порушення законів війни серед
полонених які там є є Марина
мамонова жінка вагітна на восьмому
місяці вагітності весь світ має знати
зараз про злочини росіян ми маємо знати
їх прізвище і вибачте будь ласка коли
вчора на Марафоні так званому єдиному
іде фільм 15 хвилин про права жінок
Вірніше не права жінок в Афганістані але
при цьому Жодного слова про жінок
військовополонених - це ганьба
інформаційній політиці нинішньої влади
ми вимагаємо поставити в порядок денний
законопроект 7620 - це постанова про
висвітлення діяльності Верховної Ради
України всіх вас запитують українці
Верховна Рада працює і ви не можете
нічого сказати друзі що поганого якщо в
слоті рада буде іти висвітлення
діяльності ми працюємо зараз на
збереження суб'єктності парламенту
Шановні колеги переходимо до розгляду
питань порядку денного